you know I I um I want to congratulate
JPL Jordan Peele who is also been on our
podcast he won an Oscar last night so
give him a round of applause everybody i
catched him and then he liked my text so
I didn't really get a response but you
know when someone likes your text it's
not you know it's not like a response
but it's it's kind of a [ __ ] you but not
yeah yeah me it's kind of like I have to
respond but I'm not gonna actually put
words in yeah but that's fine he was
busy last night Oscar
he probably responded to Keegan know he
probably responded to Keegan and Ike
Barinholtz probably but anyway
congratulations Jordan I love you really
big deal and I got really emotional they
aired my pilot my trailer for my sitcom
a couple times but it's fine
I look pretty good on television myself
but my point is is this we have a very
special guest now listen I've asked this
guy to do our podcast many times before
but he's always I'm in [ __ ] Canada or
I'm shooting something in France or some
[ __ ]
and I had done his podcast a million
times 10-minute podcast with him Bryan
Callen and he just wants me to [ __ ]
say his name but anyway but before I
even say his name though I want to say
this though too is this I want to say
this too is is that when I first got
into MADtv this guy was a senior cast
member on the show and really I didn't
really get a really good response from
the senior cast members except for this
guy this guy got my number we hung out
he was very welcoming to me well he's a
good guy I [ __ ] told you not to
[ __ ] say anything your [ __ ] drum
roll it's not gonna be worth it
all right Will Sasso everybody
[Applause]
welcome to the Tiger belly Oscar wrap up
something else yeah you know what you
know what that you're here man yeah I
really like I'm already happy to be here
I really though absolutely I've always
wanted to do your podcast and I happen
to be out of town I've never been to
France I was probably in Atlanta or
something yeah yeah shooting something
right yeah so your your your the trailer
for your new show was on TV yeah I did
catch a little bit of the Oscars but
last night I was in my native Canada I
was hanging out with my parents I was at
their house and we have Canadian Tire
commercials and that sort of thing all
right so yeah that's that's fine I
wasn't I didn't say that it doesn't
matter no but don't do that show love
you and Kyle and nobody ever goes
it's called splitting up together and I
think they're gonna I think they're
gonna be okay those two yeah those kids
are gonna be fine yeah and what do you
play I play the [ __ ] no I play that's my
name in a [ __ ] oh yeah yeah I have a
rice hat well you know me with those
Vietnam prize hats great no I play I'm
not by a soldier and they just pull a
gun to your head around style you know
that traumatic picture that rise to the
people we do is your hunters saying we
do the [ __ ] gun to the debt you know
yeah I just what do they call that
Russian Roulette yeah which is who
invented that game this is a game
yeah but Dave yeah but back then the way
they made games was that they would be
like games would be like gladiator games
the light and then a tiger eats you from
the inside it's not necessarily a game
to the people playing it's a game to the
people watching oh right so the like
kings and queens or like people that are
in charge
yeah they go let's watch a game you know
game should we watch basketball no as a
matter of anything
but even the Mayan basketball if you
lost you get your ball shop dogs why
what yeah the winner gets killed because
they can go right to have it or whatever
yeah honored to to die and make it to
the next level right
I think that's missing from our
modern-day sports I bet you money that
teams would win more yeah if you got
killed for if they knew that they they
law if the in the NFL if they said that
the last place team with the worst
record they're all gonna die well if you
think about it everybody that wins the
Super Bowl is always like hey I just
want to thank our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ nothing would be possible without
God blah blah blah and I'm heading home
right now and just pull a gun out like
fools god fear now watch every time I
can yeah congrats to me what is the rule
of Russian roulette though you have like
a handgun six chambers when one bullet
is in the chamber yes and you spin it
and you stick it to your thing no that's
not Russian is that it's the one where
you walk away from each other then you
turn and that's that gunslinger western
duel western yeah Russia or lettuce we
spin and then you go first click yeah
you're fine
BAM I lost it's you versus you yeah what
a [ __ ] up [ __ ] game yeah would you
be able to play if I said let's play one
round a Russian Roulette Gilbert would
you do with me what are the stakes other
than there's life your life no wrong
answer yes a yes yeah
I think it's exhilarating if you don't
lose though would you like you know how
in South South Africa there's that one
island that's just infested with great
white sharks but they said hey we'll
we'll give you a billion dollars if you
swam 200 meters from this point to the
boat no chain no chain link suit no
nothing but it's infested with great
white sharks I would do it on one
condition if I could take a shower right
before because it tend to smell like
meat
all right right that's a good that's
good yeah yeah you know what I would do
what I would just I think I would do it
for a billion dollars a lot of money
I'll tell you why I wouldn't move much I
would just let the colonel
you know I would just flow like a
jellyfish and they don't they don't
I would like to tentacles yeah I have
the body for it too and they know they'd
get stung if me right yeah you for sure
do not want to look like a dying fish
you want to look like you're able to
swim well I would yeah how about like
just I'd go over to that Halloween store
on Hollywood Boulevard get a dolphin hat
yes like a mask because they're afraid
of dolphins right yeah it'd just be a
big there for the Dolphins yeah get some
really good paint like that stuff they
put on Rebecca romaine yeah where's my
money yeah oh really I dressed up like
an orca that's not but but that
shouldn't be a part of the challenge you
should be completely naked
I would like wear like armor and padding
I would put I would wear like a mermaid
bottoms but Orca style like print yeah
yeah yeah I have my hands in tight so
those just the flippers yeah and then my
my dick and balls I would paint them
like one of those fish that stick
themselves to whales decide shark maybe
try to eat my sticker fish right but
wouldn't try to eat me because either
you just go with mistake just go in
there with like mystique and they
wouldn't [ __ ] with that I'd look like a
gigantic fishing lure right I don't want
to be shiny good I would probably either
that or Russian Roulette what would you
do I would do the shark thing rather
than Russian elapses yeah
because what are the odds in the shark
you could survive it's over I mean have
you ever seen those
videos where they do like a prosthetic
seal and they drag it with a boat and
it's like 10 for 10 the shark goes for
it really the coast of South Africa yeah
and they not only do they go for it the
sharks breach so they jump up from under
so they don't they never attack sideways
they always go from under cuz I did the
cage in South Africa
you dare me orny Adams Ian bagg wouldn't
get in the water yeah because he was
vomiting but he's Canadian yeah we
Canadian a week the ocean there is very
mellow yeah yeah but when we were in the
cage
you literally go oh I don't see nothing
yeah [ __ ] it right yeah and you're still
staying there and then all of a sudden
you don't see it the great white you
know you feel it you can literally feel
water like really go through you and
then you feel something from the bottom
and when it comes up I'm not kidding you
dude it is [ __ ] scary
Wow they don't look like I've been
around tiger sharks and other side but
the trucks are we in Hawaii we did go up
the gay ones I want to know is what was
this on fuse who watched that you and
orny Adams and me and bag you know was
that like some sort of wacky no no no we
were off II know we were in South Africa
doing a comedy festival and we're out
there for a couple of months oh yeah and
then you know Ian and those guys are
like couple of months yeah we're there
for two months why it's so we did like
[ __ ] 60 shows or something what the
[ __ ] kind of festival is that it was
like a stand-up thing and then they're
just letting you swim with sharks
they're like we got so many comedians
they're here for no they give us I think
they gave us the weekends off and then
then we like there's some weekends we
didn't do anything and then some
weekends people would plan things so we
just Safari thing and then we did that's
cool right wanted thing and yeah it was
crazy yeah that great white thing was
crazy yeah yeah why I was just curious
what why do you question me like I was
my eye or something no I'm just I don't
know what the [ __ ] you do in South
Africa
[Music]